so now we've talked about how the cash
works for updating normal files from the
cash now the whole app cache system is
actually very complex it's a very
complex algorithm that the browser goes
through to get files out of the cache
figure out whether it should update the
cache check the different sections in
the file we do want to talk briefly
about the network section for files that
always need to be loaded from the
network so let's go take a look at that
the network section we're supposed to
make it easier to build applications
that were occasionally online but it
turns out that's pretty hard to do as we
talked about before it's hard to answer
the question definitively if you're
online or offline one common thing to do
is in the network section at the bottom
to put a star or even just to only have
a star here this basically means
anything that we haven't specified
already further up in the application
cache in the cache section you should
just go to the network for this actually
isn't a great thing to do if you have
any blocking resources in your file or
in your application that haven't been
listed in the cache file its going to
sit there and wait until it times out so
what you should really do is develop
without that Network Star even if you
add it later that way your cache updates
in the console will actually show you if
you're missing files